across the South many people are
fighting to take down statues of
Confederate heroes but a new monument
just went up in Richmond Virginia the
former capital of the Confederacy the
statue sits just a few blocks from a
famous row of Confederate monuments it
was inspired by one of them a statue of
general Jeb Stewart but it sends a very
different message only on CBS this
morning
we spoke with the artist Kehinde Wiley
as the statue was unveiled to see how he
wants to create a new narrative the war
heroes of the Confederacy line
Richmond's Monument Avenue generals
robert e lee Stonewall Jackson and Jeb
Stewart there's a type of ceremony that
surrounds the valorisation of these guys
a few years ago California born Kehinde
Wiley came face to face with them for
the first time what did you see I saw a
spectacle that felt dreadful that we I
mean it almost felt like it was designed
to be menacing to be in a black body
walking through the streets of Richmond
and to see something that signifies the
enslavement of your people that's a
little bit more heavy duty the 42 year
old artist decided to answer with a
monument of his own on Tuesday
Wiley's 27 foot high bronze sculpture of
a young black man
horseback was unveiled at Virginia's
Museum of Fine Arts the new statue was
celebrated by Virginia's governor Ralph
Northam who was mired in a blackface
scandal earlier this year today we say
welcome to a progressive and inclusive
Virginia and by Richmond's mayor levar
Stoney who wants the Confederate statues
removed I don't believe they should be
on Grand Boulevard Slyke Monument Avenue
I think they should be found in museums
and cemeteries and battlefields
thousands came out for the unveiling
many standing in front of the
neighboring headquarters of the United
Daughters of the Confederacy Wylie who's
best known for his portrait of President
Obama for the National Portrait Gallery
this is your sister it is in fact my
sister yeah made his name with epic
paintings of ordinary people you've put
her in a suit of armor that's right in
fact this is a part of a body of work
that's about skin armor is a kind of
strange stand-in for race on it in a way
as well this kind of skin that is it
once so important but a burden
he's also used the horse in his earlier
work what drew you to that imagery my
work is all about power it's about the
negotiation of power the depiction of it
those who have it those who don't rumors
of war as his new sculpture is called
made its debut this fall in New York's
Times Square I wanted it to be at the
center of a global conversation and when
you think about America in lights
it's Times Square it's where the world
comes to see America who is this man
well he's anyone and no one I think it
would meant a lot to me to be able to
say that in the 21st century we as a
society can say yes to a monument to a
young black man in a hoodie then last
week it was disassembled and loaded onto
flatbeds for the trip to Richmond to
take its permanent place near the
Confederate monuments you want your
statute to be speaking back to those
statues I want my statue to be speaking
back to the people looking at those
statues so you don't think those
statutes should be taken down I think
that the best thing to do is to respond
to them with more statues disappearance
is not what I'm asking for
nor is it keeping sculptures and city
centers to horrify people mm-hmm what
I'm saying is the answer to negative
speech is more speech it's positive
speech it makes sense to have something
exist on a monumental level because this
is a monumental conversation that this
country needs to have